Ever since I can remember, I've always looked up to you.
When we were little girls, I thought you were so cool.
I did everything I could to dress and act exactly like you...
...because I wanted to be like you.
Now that I have my own taste in clothes, obviously better taste,...
...I want you to know I still consider you an incredible role model.
You've shown me what being a sister means.
Being a sister means bringing chicken noodle soup when she feels sick.
It means fighting over who gets to ride shotgun and sometimes letting her win.
Being a sister means picking her up from a party...
...when she's had too much to drink.
Being a sister means a lot of different things.
But most importantly, it means you'll always have a best friend.
Thank you for helping me grow from a girl into a woman.
I love you.